[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar novel tools for cell line
engineering with crispr cast nine
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and offers
free continuing education credits please
click on the window at the bottom of
your screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
louise baskin senior product manager for
functional genomics at thermo fisher
scientific
louise you may now begin your
presentation
thanks very much marie good morning or
good afternoon for everyone thank you
for joining
i'm really pleased to be sharing with
you today our new tool set for doing
cell line engineering with crisprcast9
so i'll be starting with a really quick
overview of gene editing with hdr or
knock in that utilizes a donor template
and cleavage by crisprcas9 i'm then
going to tell you more about the kits
that i'm introducing today with review
of the trutag donor dna workflow
this is for generating donor dnas really
quickly and easily for a very wide range
of cell line engineering applications
then we'll get into the kits with a bit
more detail of their capabilities i'll
show you some of the data we've
generated both for gene tagging as well
as creation of
engineered cell lines
and i'll close with a demonstration of
how the true design genome editor
software
which is available free online
will seamlessly support the the genomic
locus specific reagent designs
not just for using the true tag donor
dna kits but for a really wide range of
genomic edits
so genome editing is
really routinely being achieved by using
crispr cas9 or or other targeted
nucleases by creating double strand
breaks at desired locations in the
genome
the natural repair mechanisms of the
cell will heal the break by either
non-homologous and joining shown on the
left nhej
or by homology directed repair
now double strand break repair by nhej
is more error-prone
so it's frequently harnessed to rapidly
generate specific gene knockouts
um by the introduction of insertions or
deletions at that cut site
due to imperfect repair
whereas homology directed repair is more
precise because it requires a template
for repair so by providing the cell with
a synthetic template containing a
sequence of interest for example a you
know disease-specific mutation
a researcher can then introduce this
sequence into the host genome
so hdr really lets you go beyond just
simple indels for functional knockout
and do a lot more designer edits in the
genome
such as adding a fluorescent tag to your
gene for expression and localization
studies
adding an epitope tag for doing protein
isolation
without a specific antibody to your
protein of interest
introducing a stop codon for knockout of
gene function again this can be done
also with just that imperfect repair but
this is kind of a more precise
um and if you will more elegant way to
do knockout
and then there's also a lot of different
changes that can be made by introducing
a snip or other amino acid changes
potentially to model a disease
so let's talk more about the
requirements for htr this also might be
commonly referred to as knock in
the process requires not just a cas9
nuclease to make that cut in the genome
but also a guide rna designed adjacent
to that knock-in site
plus a dna donor template so that is
that again that piece of dna with
sufficient homology on each end of the
dna cut site
plus the region that includes your
desired edit again this could be an
insertion a snip change or a or a
fluorescent tag
so there's three required components
for doing an hdr edit with crispr cas9
but the type of dna donor is going to
depend on the size of the insertion and
the dna region being targeted and the
proper donor design is really really
important for effective genome editing
there's a number of common obstacles
that we hear about often that
researchers find when carrying out cell
line engineering using hdr
one is the design of the guide rna and
the donor dna so this step requires
proper homology arms of the donor while
taking into account the cut site
location and the edit site location
along the genome
so without a single uh you know design
tool to assist with this step there can
be a lot of time lost and potential
errors made and let's face it not all of
us are experts in in doing designs like
this
second donor templates for tagging or
large knock-in are often plasmid-based
um and this can involve multiple steps
for assembly
growth of subcultures and
characterization again a step where
there's a lot of room for error and also
taking a lot of time
and then lastly hdr has a generally low
knock-in efficiency i mean even in a
really well-designed experiment so this
means you may not have
many cells to work with in establishing
a robust population that contains your
edit of interest so you might end up
needing to isolate you know grow up and
characterize many many hundreds of cells
so what we hope to accomplish in the
development of these tools is to take
out a lot of these really time consuming
steps
making the design steps a lot easier and
taking steps to improve the overall
editing efficiency
so the kits that i want to discuss today
address many of these issues so they let
you generate dna donors for tagging or
knockout really quickly and easily with
just a pcr step so there's no cloning
required no plasmid manipulation
they include enrichment markers to
obtain nearly 100 edited cells letting
you save you know potentially up to four
months when compared to more traditional
workflows
and since each knock-in is completely
unique to the gene of interest we
provide the true design genome editor
software which i'll demonstrate for you
later
and we've really made it a very seamless
and easy way to do gene tagging and
knockout cell line development
so a little more detail on the type of
kits i'm going to discuss today
so the true tag donor dna kit for gfp
and rfp tagging were launched in 2019
and much more recently just a few weeks
ago we launched a much wider selection
of kits in this portfolio so we've
really expanded the capabilities for
doing fluorescent tagging with different
types of genes as well as different
expanding the different colors that we
offer
and we now have four different kits for
doing epitope tagging
and we now have a kit that is
specialized for knockout cell line
development so i'll talk you through all
of these and show you some data
um but i want to start really with just
kind of what does the workflow look like
for for any and all of these kits
so let's talk first about just preparing
that dna donor again that that required
part
um
of the system to do the the targeted
repair
so the basics of creating uh the dna
template for knocking using the true tag
kits is really very straightforward
so primers that contain the unique
homology arms to your
genomic site can be designed and ordered
from the true design software
and then they're used to amplify the dna
donor template that's provided in the
kit
using pcr
reagents that are also provided in the
kit the following pcr that donor dna
will now have the locus specific
homology arms added to it and then it's
simply purified with a spin column that
is provided
so all of this can be done in just a few
hours and then you've got your
transfection ready dna donor
so now look at that workflow compared to
one provided with the competitors kit
that utilizes a vector for cloning and
amplification of the dna donor
so this workflow is also very similar to
what you might do if you were doing
uh you know a homebrew or do-it-yourself
starting with basic molecular biology
components so i'm not going to walk
through all of these steps
but i really just wanted to illustrate
all of the
amplification and ligation and
transformation and colony picking
all these places where not only you
might introduce variation
it's just time it takes days or weeks
instead of hours to get to
a transfection-ready dna donor using
that workflow
then once you have your donor the true
tag workflow is really only days away
from an enriched edited cell population
with your knock-in of interest
so step one is to deliver the donor
along with a cas9 nucleus and a guide
rna that's targeting an appropriate
region in your genome
following that step some subset of your
cells will get that knock in of the
donor
following the cas9 cleavage and the
repair
so now that you've got that you can now
enrich that cell population using the
antibiotic resistance marker provided in
the true tag template so you can then
isolate a more pure population of your
edited cells
and then from that population
you can use sequencing primers to verify
your insertion and you can use cree
locks to remove that resistance marker
to not have it in the background of your
cells any longer if you desire to do so
so now i want to take you through the
different applications and the kits that
have been developed
and show you some of the results of each
of these four experiment types
so i'm going to start with our kits for
fluorescent and epitope gene tagging
so these are the diagrams of either the
fluorescent or the epitope tag templates
that are provided in the true tag kits
so all of them will provide the option
to knock in either at the n or the c
terminus of your gene
now generally speaking the c terminus
might be recommended so as to not
interfere with
native gene regulators but we've also
had success with n-terminal tagging as
well
and since each knock-in as i've said is
completely unique to your gene of
interest you do need to provide those
primers to amplify the donor while also
adding on the specific homology arms to
enable the hdr repair and that's where
the true design software comes in as i
said i'll i'll demonstrate that for you
later
now the templates provided in the kit
enable knock-in of your desired tag
plus an enrichment marker for either
blastocyte and or pure mice and
resistance and then as i mentioned you
have the option to then remove that
marker following enrichment of the cell
population
and as you can see both the fluorescent
tag and the resistance marker are being
driven off of the endogenous promoter
for the gene that you're targeting
um here are some results using the true
tag kits for both the n and the c
terminal tagging templates
um here we used gfp to tag the beta
actin gene and here you can obviously
see really very good gfp expression with
both of those strategies
and just to illustrate that enrichment
you can see how the enrichment using
that selection marker can get to a
nearly pure population of gfp-tagged
cells
by day three of selection you can see we
start to visually
see that gfp tag appear and about 25 of
the cells are showing gfp enrichment
in doing cell sorting and by day 10
we're at essentially a stable gfp
expressing pool of cells with almost 100
percent
of the population expressing that tag
so new to the truetag product family is
the ability to tag with either blue or
yellow fluorescent protein so these
options came out of customer requests
for having
more colors
to do tagging of more proteins in the
same cell
each of those proteins getting their own
distinct color
so on the right you can see the facts
analysis for the parental cells i'm
using either the bfp or the yfp
and you can see those parental cells
essentially have zero
percent of cells expressing either the
yellow or the blue
and following dosing of pure mycin or
blastocytin you can see a very strong
shift in that population of fluorescent
cells
and then we've quantified that in the
bar graph on the right
showing that increase in tagged cells
as the dosage of the antibiotic is
increased so here both experiments we
managed to
exceed 80 tagged cells in the population
following that enrichment step
and here we're just demonstrating that
the appropriate fluorophore is being
co-expressed with the tagged protein um
so here on the top we've got gfp on the
bottom we've got rfp both were used to
tag that beta actin gene and the center
image in each panel showing cells being
counterstained with a phalloidin
antibody to detect that native actin
protein so as you can see with the
overlay uh in both the tags are being
properly co-expressed with that gene of
interest
next i'm going to go into some data for
another type of gene tagging that's new
to the truetag family and so this is for
adding an epitope tag to a protein of
interest so we offer four different
epitope tags and for anyone not familiar
these are
small proteins
that can enable the use of a standard
antibody to recognize that small protein
for tracking or isolating your protein
of interest and so you might do this to
study and isolate a novel protein where
an antibody is not available
so here's a demonstration of cells being
successfully enriched after knocking
using all four of our different epitope
tag kits
utilizing both the pure mycin or the
blastocytin
resistance marker
so the upper row on each set of western
blots is showing that higher percentage
of cells
expressing that tag upon the stronger
selection conditions and then we've
included gap bh as a loading control for
each western
now in the upper right i do just want to
point out the kit known as ddk so that
tag is an octapeptide that's also
commonly known as the flag tag
which is very common to use in this type
of study
and the others you probably can
recognize h.a mick and 6s hiss are also
very commonly used in this type of
application
so as we did with the fluorescent tags
we wanted to verify appropriate
co-localization of the epitope with the
tagged protein so again here we used an
anti-h a antibody so that's our tag
shown in green and then an anti-beta
actin
antibody shown in red and again we're
seeing really nice overlay
to demonstrate that expected
co-localization of the tag with the
protein of interest
now i'm going to talk about fluorescent
tagging in a slightly different context
so this is
one that was actually designed with stem
cells in mind but could also be used for
tagging of any unexpressed gene
so as i just showed you
a few slides ago our fluorescent tagging
kits are really effective at tagging
expressed genes
and here we see that
example
in
gfp expression of a tag that was added
to again the beta actin gene but this
time in human stem cells and we really
got nice ongoing effectiveness of that
tag
after the cells were differentiated into
various lymphoid and myeloid cell types
but our true tag stem kits have some
additional advantages for gene tagging
where the protein of interest may not be
expressed but you still can enrich for
your tagged cells in addition we can you
can choose between the tag being fused
to the protein or have it cleaved
and this can prevent that tag from
potentially interfering with any protein
activity
so let's look at those templates now so
the true tag gfp and rfp stem donor
templates have slightly different
construction
than the ones i showed you that are
designed for tagging of express genes
so similarly the fluorescent tag is
driven from that endogenous promoter of
your gene of interest so it will only
express when your protein is expressed
however the pure mycin or blastocyte and
resistance marker has their own promoter
so you can carry out enrichment on
edited cells even if your tagged protein
is not being expressed
so this is an example of that
truetag gfp stem kit in action
so we tagged ipsc cells on the
c-terminus of the g-fap gene
and this is a gene that codes for an
intermediate filament protein that is
found only in mature astrocytes
so after six days of pure myosin
selection
we proceeded to treat those tagged cells
with a neural induction media for seven
days
and then with astrocyte differentiation
media for another 45 days
so as you can see by day 18 we started
to see gfp expression as that gfap gene
was being activated and by day 45 nearly
all of our cells were expressing that
gfp tag
and so again we always want to confirm
that our gfp signal is being driven by
that gfap gene or our target genes
expression
so again we stained ourselves with an
anti-gsap antibody that's the second
column shown in red
and then that red staining um was shown
to overlap really nicely with gfp so
once again indicating we're getting that
gfp tag signal because the expression of
g-fat protein was triggered in the
mature astrocytes
now i do just want to say that it's
important to note that the intensity of
any tag is always going to be dependent
on the endogenous expression level so
weak native expression is going to mean
a weak fluorescent signal but here we
had really good
expression of our native protein to give
us that good gfp
tag
so another unique feature of the trutag
stem kits as i mentioned a few slides
ago is that you have the option
to choose a fusion or a non-fusion tag
so that is you can use a template that
has a 2a cleavable linker such that the
fluorophore is not directly fused to the
target protein so this might be of
interest in cases where
there's concerns that the tag would
maybe interfere with the target protein
expression or its folding
and both of these templates are provided
in the stem kits so you don't
necessarily have to make that decision
right away you can choose between the
two if you
are concerned that this might be an
issue for your protein of interest
so now i'm going to shift to a different
workflow that's actually really very
popular for disease modeling and for
functional studies and this is how we
use a true tag kit designed to enrich
cells that have a functional knockout of
a gene of interest
now ever since we came out with
pre-designed crispr cast 9 guide rnas
for doing knock out i'm using that indel
formation with the imperfect repair
we've gotten a lot of feedback about
the difficulty and the time needed to
isolate and characterize cells to obtain
a pure population that have bialic
knockout of their gene of interest
people are looking for
verification that both alleles have been
knocked out they're looking for ways to
enrich their edited cells or have some
visual
indication that the gene actually got
knocked out
um and so the last kit we're going to
cover was designed to address a lot of
those concerns so it's called the true
tag knockout enrichment donor dna kit
and so it does knock out by inserting a
donor that has stop codons
plus a fluorescent tag plus enrichment
markers so the workflow gives you
knockout cells in days or weeks instead
of months
plus we have a novel strategy to confirm
by allelic knockout
so here's a diagram of the truetag donor
dna template for knockout enrichment so
unlike with gene tagging where we target
the n or the c terminus for insertion
this cassette can be inserted anywhere
within the target coding region because
we don't really care about disrupting a
gene that we're going to knock out
although we do ensure um the true design
software will ensure that we do have
in-frame insertion
so that the selection marker being
expressed for the native promoter
will be expressed properly
there's a cmv promoter that is used to
drive the fluorophore expression for
visualization and cell sorting
and the template then also includes
three stop codons to interrupt
translation in all three reading frames
so as with our other templates cree
locks can be used to remove the
enrichment and fluorescent markers to
leave you with only cells that have
those stop codons to maintain that
functional knockout without any other
elements being left behind in your cell
line
so there's a strategy we take with the
knockout enrichment kit to address what
it has been
you know told to us is a very common
issue
how can you determine
if only one allele if a cell is knocked
out as opposed to both
so you can imagine that a strategy using
insertion of gfp and stop codons to
knock in to disrupt the gene
you wouldn't necessarily be able to tell
the difference between cells that have
both alleles edited or only one because
they're both expressing that gfp
so how can you ensure that both alleles
have that insertion of the stop codons
to knock out you know to fully knock out
the target protein expression
so the true tag approach is to use dual
labeling and dual selection for knockout
enrichment by combining the donors into
pairs one with each fluorophore and each
resistance marker
so this lets you ensure by allelic
knockout since for some subset of cells
one allele is going to get inserted
we'll get insertion of each donor so
you'll have copies of each of these
donors in some subset of your cells
now it is going to be a smaller
proportion of the cell population but
because you've got dual antibiotic
resistance to enrich for cells that have
both events
you're able to isolate those cells
and know that both alleles have been
disrupted
so here's an example where we used both
combinations of fluorescent resistance
markers in the upper and lower sections
here
where we did our dual enrichment with
pure mycin and blastocytin and then
conducted cell sorting
so in each case when compared to the
parental cell control the sorted cells
exhibited around 70 gfp and rfp positive
so indicating that that dual enrichment
of cells
gave us knock-ins that have both
templates
that is both gfp and rfp therefore more
likely to also have bialic knockout
and so here we show the target gene
knockout analysis results by western
blot so on the right you can see the
cell sorting again really good
enrichment of the dual
positive rfp and gfp but we're also in
those cells able to get essentially
total knockout of our target gene which
in this case was hprt
so to establish a clonal cell line using
traditional methods someone would have
to do single cell isolation
from the original edited population and
in this case here that was 67 percent
expression still remaining of hprt
so then that means you're growing up
many many hundreds of cells and
characterizing each colony looking for a
biolic knockout
so the true tag kits save a ton of time
and effort by providing you with a cell
population with much much higher
knockout to start from for doing that
clonal cell line development
so here's the list of all the true tank
kits that are now available i covered at
least one example of each and then this
is the website where you can find more
information thermofisher.com backslash
truetag
there's a number of different great
resources available there
obviously the user guide if you want to
get a better idea of actually doing
these experiments
we've got workflow guides for using the
software as well as some other
supporting pieces
and a lot of data on our website
including some of the things i just
showed you
so just to quickly re-emphasize the
shared benefits of all of the true tag
kits so you're able to generate dna
donors much faster with one-step pcr
instead of doing cloning
you're able to save weeks of time with
enrichment of tagged cells urine using
the pure mycin or blastocyte and
resistance markers
to really be able to isolate your cells
with successful knock-in to rapidly
obtain a more pure population
third following enrichment the marker
can be removed with creelox
and lastly this is all supported by the
true design genome editor software so
really straightforward design and
ordering of gene-specific guide rnas the
homology arm primers as well as
validation primers
so speaking of that software i'm going
to start that demo now but want to give
you just a quick overview into
the types of things that i'm going to
show you so as i mentioned in the
opening
crispr cas9 and other engineered
nucleases are really driving a lot of
innovation in cell line engineering
so i've just covered our trutag donor
dna kits to enable fluorescent tagging
epitope tagging and enrichment of cells
with target gene knockout however i
don't want to overlook the additional
capabilities of the true design genome
software as a standalone tool
so i'll be showing you how the software
carries out
both the locus specific reagent design
for support of the trutag kits
but i'll also give you a look into how
it enables other types of genomic edits
such as deletions or insertions of up to
30 nucleotides
snip edits or other replacements for
modifying target genes
and it also supports a stop codon
insertion workflow if you want to use
that method without the truetag knockout
enrichment kit
and then finally it also designs crispr
guide rnas or talons anywhere across a
coding region for doing in-dell
formation
for knockout or any other application
that might require a double strand break
at a particular location
now the two tag kits as i showed you
utilize this long double strand dna
donor generated from pcr amplification
from a provided template whereas the
standalone edits that i'll show you
supported by the true design software
all will utilize single stranded dna
donors of around 100 nucleotides in
length and then these then will be able
to be ordered directly from the software
now i'm going to jump over to the
software and demonstrate how to use it
with those true tag kits as well as
using it on its own for precise gene
editing
okay so here we are at the um the what
i'll call the landing page if you will
for the true design genome editor
software um this is available at
thermofish.com backslash two design
um and it gives you a really nice
overview into the types of experiments
that are supported
um there's a lot of easy access to um
kind of quick user guides that kind of
walk you through the different steps
of each workflow
um if you keep scrolling you can see
kind of some schematics of all the
different products and and really what's
going to happen inside your cells
and there's also some nice videos that
that kind of let you visualize and walk
through it
to make sure you understand all the
steps that are involved
so there's a number of ways to access
the tool we've got a few different links
on this page you can jump to
i'll go ahead and start at the one right
here at the top
and if you haven't already logged in
to a thermo fisher account it is going
to prompt you
to do a login
so here it knows my username and you
might be thinking ugh i don't want to do
a login i don't want to be getting a
bunch of email it's actually incredibly
straightforward to do this all you have
to provide is a name and an email and
that's it
you can opt out of any you know
additional mailing lists
and it gives you access to this entire
set of cloud tools
called thermo connect and so there's
actually a lot of really amazing
analytical tools
that you have access to in addition to
what i'm about to show you
do a quick login
all right so now here is the um the
start page for the true design genome
editor again showing you the six
different types of gene editing
experiments that we offer
i'm going to start with gene tagging
because this is going to be able to
excuse me show you the workflow for a
lot of the kits that i just demonstrated
so click on gene tagging and then i just
click next
and so now it's going to ask me what
what gene am i interested in so you can
see here we offer five different species
human mouse rats zebrafish and c elegans
i'm going to go ahead and use human
for the majority of the time you're
probably just going to want to select
your gene by entering your gene symbol
or an enter id i will show you one
example where it's useful to do this by
location but generally speaking you're
going to know what gene you're working
on
so i will just go ahead and enter a gene
of interest
and click it from the drop down once i
see my gene and i'll click search
and so now it's bringing back all the
transcripts associated with that gene
for a lot of genes human especially
there are multiple
versions splice variants of different
genes so the first one listed for both
human and mouse is always going to be um
what's known as the refseq select
transcript so the one that is really
kind of considered the most prevalent
the most common but you might know
you're the best expert on your gene
there might be a certain variant that is
specific to a disease or something that
you want to work with
if you ever need to we have these really
quick links that immediately go out to
ncbi so you can visualize the
transcripts if you need to remind
yourself
of which is which but generally speaking
i typically just pick the first one
click next
just let me orient you really quickly to
what
this page is showing you so along the
top it's got the entire
transcript topology of um my transcript
of interest
and then what's shown at the sequence
editor at the nucleotide level below is
whatever is in this blue box
so i can click and drag on that box if i
want to jump to a different exon
um if i need to zoom in and out i can do
that with these buttons here to get a
little closer look
but there's a lot of different ways to
kind of decide what area you might want
to play with but with doing gene tagging
as i showed you we're really just
choosing either the n
or the c terminus so it will it will
automatically adjust to that when we go
through the workflow
so the three different tag options are
fluorescent tag of an express gene
fluorescent tag of a non-expressed gene
which is that workflow i showed you with
the stem
gfp and rfp kits
or epitope tagging of an express gene
so i'll just go ahead and click the
epitope tag workflow
and so it's going to kind of use this
mini wizard to kind of walk through all
the different decision making of what
you need to do these designs
so as i mentioned it lets you choose
either the n or the c terminus i'm going
to click the c terminus
and then here's where i can choose which
tag i might want to use so i'll click
the mic tag
and then lastly you choose between your
blastocytin and pure mice and resistance
markers
so once you've made all those selections
the add tag button will be enabled
and once you click it it'll bring up an
edit list so you can see here the
sequence editor automatically jumped to
the c terminus of my gene
it's indicating that it will insert that
mick puro tag right here ahead of the
stop codon
um it gives me my reference locus um it
shows me here in the edit list
what it is i'm i'm adding or changing in
this case a mcpiro tag
if i decide i would rather do something
else
you don't want to hit the back button
and you'll see that this is all grayed
out it's grayed out because right now it
thinks this is my edit of interest
so if i want to redo that i just click
this undo button
and then if i want to for instance i can
click a different
tag or a different
selection marker so once i click that
it's then going to refresh my edit list
and then once i click next it's going to
go through and look for guide rna
designs that are in my region to make a
cut
adjacent to
my insertion site and it's going to do
specificity checking on all of those
guides so that i understand the
potential for off targets in my
experiment and then lastly it's going to
design those primers for doing the
homology arm amplification
um or excuse me homology arm addition as
well as the template amplification
so in the time it took me to say that it
finished my designs
um and so what it's going to do is show
me uh the designs that are available in
the region of interest we try and keep
it to within
10 base pairs up and down stream from
the edit site
if i click on different results in my
table you can see it's kind of showing
me where the different guide rnas lay
on my template
for each guide it'll show you the
sequence
it'll show you the pam site these green
check marks indicate that these are the
two that might be highest recommended
um the score is our algorithm score so
how likely is this guide going to be a
good efficient
cutter how well is it likely to cut so
the highest score you can get is a
hundred percent
um and then so everything is relative to
that
it shows me the number of predicted off
targets and if i actually click on this
it'll bring up a list of the predicted
off targets
so see you can see here
what the off target recognition site is
what that off target pam site is
it lists the mismatches as well as
showing them here in red in the sequence
so here you can see this has three
mismatches at locations one seven and
nine
and it tells me where on what chromosome
that off target might occur
so if you want to you can have that
whole list here you can see the same off
target might appear even twice
and this is a case where you might want
to think about using a high fidelity
cast 9 to reduce the likelihood of those
again that all is kind of up to your own
comfort level
the next field is going to show you the
edit site distance from
you know how far away is the cut from
the edit site
and then lastly it's going to show you
the homology arm amplification primers
so again these are critical for
amplifying that true tag donor dna
that's provided in the kit so the green
sequence is the conserved region
that will always be able to pair with
the template in the kit
and then the black region i'll just
highlight it here so you can see it
better
is going to be the homology arms that
are specific to not just your gene of
interest but specific to this guide rna
so you can see the homology arms are
slightly different
for each of these different guides
because they occur at slightly different
positions along the transcript
so once you're ready to make a selection
you just click the check box
and the next button will be enabled you
click next and now you get to what we
call our summary screen
and so this is really everything you
need to do your gene tagging experiment
so starting in the upper left it's all
the crispr reagents so here it's showing
me
uh that guide rna
we provide these as synthetic single
guys rnas at 1.5 nanimal amounts
you have a number of different cas9
formats to choose from
um the true cut cas9 protein is kind of
our standard a very high performing
casting protein
maybe if i'm nervous about those off
targets i saw i might choose the high
fidelity cast line just to feel a little
more confident that i'll have fewer off
targets
if i want to buy a different size
or quantity of that protein i can do
that here
and then it also will prompt you to
order the appropriate transfection
reagent
so for us that's the lipofectum in
crispr max
again different sizes are available if
you already have some of this in your
fridge
you obviously can uncheck that
and then of course you'll have the
trutag donor primers used to do that
amplification and homology arm
step
over on the right it's always going to
prompt
or give you the option
to order primers for genomic cleavage
detection or for sequencing so these are
really just for looking at how well did
your crisper actually cut
so you can see here it'll actually show
you which primers it suggests for it in
reverse it tells you the amplicon size
for doing that detection assay to to
assess the efficiency
and then lastly for any of the tagging
experiments you're going to have the
reagents you need the kit itself right
because i chose the 6s hiss
tag it's going to prompt me to buy that
kit and then it's also going to design
for me verification primers so these are
for use after i've enriched my cell line
it'll do junction pcr to verify that i
have my insertion in the right place
and then here you can see there's other
products it's prompting me if i want to
buy any of our positive controls for
human
or a negative control or if i want to i
can add that jean art genomic cleavage
detection kit
to my cart immediately
so i can either download these designs
in the protocol i'll show you that in a
moment or i can just add these directly
to my cart
so clicking that then opened my cart and
it shows you now all of those products
that i just talked about um so here's
our
guide rna
here are our true tag forward and
reverse primers
here is our forward and reverse
sequencing primers
verification primers the hifi protein
that i selected
the crispr max cas9 transfecture agent
my donor dna kit and my genomic cleavage
detection kit so it was really easy for
me to kind of build that shopping list
and add everything i needed all at once
i'm actually going to hop back to the
software to show you a few more
demonstrations so here you can see it
says the items were added to my cart
i'll click ok
i'm actually going to jump backwards
to start a new experiment
there's a few different ways to do this
you saw there was that start a new
experiment button or you can just use
these prompts to navigate
i want to now show you the gene knockout
enrichment
workflow so for that i'd select gene
knockout as the type of gene editing
experiment i want to carry out
then i'm going to click next
again prompting me for my species and
for my gene of interest i'm going to go
ahead and use that same gene
so able 1
select it from the list and click search
again it's got my two transcripts of
interest i'm going to use that same one
and click next
so again i'm back to that same view it's
showing me the transcript topology it's
showing me everything at um the
nucleotide and amino acid level
but now it's prompting me to select a
knockout strategy
so as i mentioned we can just do basic
crispr cast 9 designs for doing a
frameshift indel
wouldn't necessarily recommend that
using this workflow for human and mouse
because we have pre-designed guide rnas
for those but if you're working in those
other species
rats c elegans or zebrafish this is a
great way to grade
guide rnas for those
you can insert a stop codon again in the
absence of the enrichment kit but i
really want to show you how that
knockout enrichment kit design works
so as i mentioned there's always that
paired strategy for doing the donors
so really it's a question of do you want
gfp to be paired with pure mycin or with
blast and then vice versa for the rfp so
i'm going to choose that second option
and now because i'm working in human
and because it doesn't matter if i'm at
the c or the n-terminus it's asking me
do i want to use the pre-designed guide
rnas again these are
thermal products that are sold as
standalone products
but they've been predicted with our
algorithm to be highly efficient and
highly specific
um so i'd probably recommend doing that
when it's an available option for
knockout enrichment
but if you have a certain region that
you know you want your stop codon to be
in for some you know you know
some knowledge you have about your
protein you can choose custom but i'm
going to go ahead and choose
pre-designed and most of the steps are
going to look
the same for each
and so now it's just going to look for
all of the pre-designed guides and again
it's going to build those homology on
primers and it's going to do
the specificity checking and bring back
the off targets
all right so now it has brought me the
four different pre-designed guides um so
this view is going to be very much like
what we saw for the tagging except
instead of at the c or the n-terminus
they're going to be within the coding
region
and as you can see as i click on
different ones you can see this one was
designed in exon 3. if i click down here
this one was designed in exon 2.
all the other data is going to be very
similar to the other tagging results i
showed you
i will call out that these have very
very high scores again these were
generated because i chose pre-designed
these are generated by our algorithms so
excellent scores and really excellent
off targets
or lack of off targets if you will um
and again the homology arm primers that
are going to be used to amplify
that insert that gives me
the fluorophore the selection marker as
well as the stop codons so again i can
click a result
click next
and it's giving me essentially those
same prompts here it's prompting me to
buy the knockout enrichment donor kit
because that's the type of experiment i
chose but everything else is essentially
the same
i do want to show you really quickly i
would recommend
every time you use
do a new experiment here to download
your results file
so it'll just come up here as a excel
file
with a bunch of different tabs with a
lot of really good information
what it's going to look like it's going
to give you all of the design
information so it's telling me
what i did uh what i selected
um it's showing me which products would
be added to my cart
so again kind of like what i showed you
in the cart it's showing me the the
guide rna the primers
the ford and reverse primers for doing
sequencing
as well as the true tag um
sequencing uh primers as well whoops
sorry a little jumpy here um all my
sequence information is here the types
of products i've added
um
all of the off target information
uh is available the sequencing primers
everything's in that file and i would
really recommend doing that download so
that you have it at your disposal
um so now that i've shown you that i'm
actually going to start a new experiment
now i want to show you a few of the oh
it's warning me yes i'm okay with losing
this data
now i want to show you some of the
workflows that are available
in the absence of the true tag donor
kits what if you just want to do
other manipulations to your transcript
of interest so that's what these are for
so we're going to do now
a replacement experiment where we're
going to swap out
some amino acids and and make a
modification to the coding region
um
just to do something different i'm going
to jump to mouse
click next
i'll do that gene symbol again
here i'm going to choose the apo e gene
might be of interest someone working in
alzheimer's
click search gene again it's going to
bring me up all the transcripts
again if there's certain transcripts
that you know are
unique or interesting if for some reason
that's really up to you to make that
decision
i'm just going to pick the first one and
click next
and now you're going to see a slightly
different
look so we still have this ability to
navigate
just by clicking and dragging
two different exons it shows up at the
sequence level in the sequence editor
view
i'm going to actually play around over
here
and so what it's prompting me now is to
select a region for replacement
so because we're doing these as hundred
nucleotide
um single stranded dna donors i am
limited to about 30 base pairs because i
still need to have those
homology arm regions in my donor to get
good knock in
but you can still do a lot within 30
bases so i'm actually going to choose to
replace
these two alanines with guanines
so i do that just by selecting a region
then typing in my modified sequence so
you'll see once i hit okay it's going to
change those alanines
and now it's indicating that those now
with my six base pair replacement those
will now encode guanines so if that's
what i want to do i can click next you
can see here again it's always going to
bring up that edit list
it shows me where my changes what my
changes if i want to change it i just
click the undo button but instead i'm
going to go ahead and click next and
generate those guide rnas
so it's still going to do that same
guide rna and actually talon designs as
well i didn't really mention that during
the true tag demonstration but it will
also generate talons in case there isn't
um a good guide rna target in my region
of interest
it also is then going to design my dna
donor to do that six base pair
replacement
okay so here are the results that came
up with it found three pretty high
scoring guide rnas
so again clicking on them is going to
show me where they are relative to my
six base pair replacement everything
else is the same in the examples i
already showed you and except here now
i'm seeing the donor dna instead of
homology arms so this is actually the
oligo that you would use as your donor
to do that knock in so the yellow
highlighted areas are the homology arms
and that orange area is showing me the
six base pair replacement that's going
to happen
and as you can see the adjustments are
being made in the donor based on
where the guide rna
might cut so based on the cut site
differences it's going to give a
slightly different donor
and again everything here is the same
you click which
set of products you want to work with
click next
now it's showing me okay for your
replacement here's my donor dna here's
my guide rna
obviously it's not prompting you for any
of the true tag products you can still
get
uh your genomic cleavage detection
sequencing primers you can still get now
it's showing me the positive control for
mouse
since i selected mouse as my
species of interest and those other
products are also available again you
can download this as a results file
maybe you need to send it to someone
else you know to do the ordering or you
can immediately add descartes
all right there's one more example i
want to show you even though i could
probably do this all day long
um so instead of a replacement i just
want to show you um how to do a snip
edit because there's some some kind of
neat functionalities that you can do
here
so clicking next
i'm going to go to human
and since i'm working in something like
a snip i probably know exactly where
that happens so rather than entering my
gene and kind of you know navigating by
clicking and dragging i can just enter
the chromosome locus location of where i
know that snip happens
so i'm going to work with that apoe gene
this time in human
which i happen to know uh lies on
chromosome 19.
oops
then you enter kind of a start and a
stop site that will span your area of
interest
so enter that
then i'm just going to add a few more
nucleotides onto it
so the length you have to enter
something that's at least 50 up to 200
bases
in terms of that region
now when you click get dna it's going to
go find what transcripts actually occur
on that portion of the chromosome so
here it found all these different
variants of the apoe gene
i'm going to go ahead and select this
first one again if you have knowledge of
certain transcript variants
this is your chance to to modify those
click next
and so now you can see here it jumped
exactly to that region that i indicated
so now i'm in the middle of exon 4.
and you'll recall that i selected a snip
experiment so now just like with my uh
with my other experiment i'm just going
to click on one base
and it's going to prompt me now okay you
chose a c what do you want to edit that
to
i'm going to do a c to t
snip change there
and again it brings it up in my edit
list it tells me where it tells me what
i'm changing
but because i'm working with
a 100 nucleotide
donor dna i'm able to do some other
changes as long as i'm not drifting too
far away up or downstream from this
first mutation
so i'm actually going to add a second
mutation so i click that plus sign
and i can add either an insertion a
deletion or
what i'm going to choose is a second
snip edit
so just an example of where i can do
that again i can just click a different
location
again i chose a c i want that to also be
a t mutation
and again you can edit or undo either of
these i'm going to go ahead and click
next to start that design step
again this is going to be the same for
again it's bringing up guide rnas if it
can't find
good scoring guide rnas it will also
bring me talons as an option
all right so here's my results again
guide rnas these happen to be really
nice scoring
really good
off target profile and again now here
it's showing me my donor that's going to
incorporate both of those snip edits as
well as giving me the homology arms in
that same donor
i've mentioned talons a couple of times
i'm just going to click on that tab so
you can see what that might look like
this is super useful um
not not just as an alternative to cast 9
but sometimes you might not find a pam
site of interest
near your edit site and so
if there's no pam site there's no way to
make a guide rna so talons are kind of
agnostic in terms of where they can be
designed to
um so they work in pairs these can be
purchased as
mrnas i'll go ahead and click one of
these to show what that looks like in
the cart
and again so it's showing you kind of up
and down stream the two different sites
it would it would cut to do the donor
dna insertion
so i can go back to my guide rna results
maybe i want to buy a guide as well
click next
and so you can see here it's populated
this lower portion showing me
the talon products the recommended
transfection reagent we have for that
because these are mrna we do recommend
the messenger max transfection reagent
and then again everything else is
similar primers for doing
cleavage detection as well as potential
controls and then you would just click
add to cart and you're done
and so with that
i think we can go ahead and take
questions i'll switch back to a slide
and turn it back over to marie to do any
kind of instructions for the q a section
thank you louise for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q and a portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
are the fluorescent proteins monomers or
dimers
oh that is a really good question and i
should have mentioned that um so these
are all monomers um so the the full
names of them if you will it's an
emerald gfp
and then it's a tag rfp tag bfp and tag
yfp so this is
um these are versions of the
fluorescent proteins that have been
optimized for
protein localization
and they do really well with uh you know
stable expression in long-term cultures
um these are licensed from evergen so
you can probably go to their website
learn a little more about them
um but that's but those are the they are
monomeric
all right next question will the
software tell me how to make the
knockout enrichment designs to make sure
i silence all variants of my gene
that is an excellent question and that's
actually something we kind of wrestled
with in designing the software
was should we
somehow do the
analysis if you will to find the common
regions
across all transcripts
so that someone can be sure that they're
knocking out
all versions of the gene
but as soon as we started thinking down
that path
we found a case where someone might only
want to silence one variant so for
instance if there's one variant that
uh you know has an extra x on or is
missing an axon or something that is uh
you know therapeutically relevant about
that that might be the only one you want
to silence
um
and so we didn't want to do too much
we didn't want to have too many
preconceptions over what someone might
want to do
and that is why really we created that
link to be able to jump directly to the
ncbi website so then you can visualize
really easily you know with the most
up-to-date genomic information you can
visualize how the transcripts align with
each other
where the unique regions are versus the
not unique regions
because we really need it to be up to
the researcher to determine
which variant they should be tran uh
editing based on what the they want the
outcome of that experiment to be
right thank you
next question
will these tagging kits work in c
elegans
oh um so c elegans is one of the species
that we offer for doing the guide rna
and
the homology on primer designs
um
we we uh thermoscientists have not
actually done these use these tags in
in c elegans
um so that you know as long as hdr works
uh in a in an organism it it should the
kit should work
um
i will i will say though if you may as i
noted in the software demo we do only
have designs
um for five different genomes um so
obviously c elegans is one of those so
you should be able to use that very
easily along with
zebrafish
rat human and mouse
but if you're working in something else
um you would you'd unfortunately kind of
be on your own for doing that design or
using some other third-party tool
but if you're able to design
a guide and the appropriate homology arm
primers the kits should still work in in
virtually any species
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question
what are the time point recommendations
for doing the ipsc differentiation
so differentiation i am not a stem cell
expert i'll make sure i start with that
differentiation can be very tricky
um and in terms of time frames how long
it takes your protein of interest
to be expressed how long it takes it to
be expressed at a high enough level to
see your tag
that all really should be optimized
before you even start
a tagging experiment
um like the example i showed you i think
it was like a 45 days
into the neural induction media or the
astrocyte differentiation step
but other differentiation other
differentiation
uh strategies might take less time or
might take more time um so that's really
going to be up to
um
optimizing that part of the workflow and
it's it's really independent of
the tagging kit itself
um we do believe that the tagging will
be successful we do believe that you can
do that enrichment
um to get more uh tagged cells out at
the end of the differentiation but you
know you'd have to you'd have to contact
our stem cell teams
uh or tech support to really figure out
if that's uh you know if there's
troubleshooting or help needed there
thank you louise do you have any final
comments for our audience
i don't other than i hope that you know
people doing this work will will um you
know create a quick login and try out
the software and see if this is
something that might be of interest to
them and obviously you know reach out to
our tech support teams download the user
guide you know do anything you need to
do to learn a little more we look
forward to these being
embraced by the the cell line
engineering groups
thank you again louise for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you